we're almost at the halfway point there
will be plenty of teams that will have
played half their schedule after week 8
some teams have had byes so there only
will be seven games in come this weekend
but the season is rocketing along and
the best and the worst teams starting to
come into focus with a large gap Chris
if teams in the middle that could break
either way and we've seen teams remember
the Patriots 2001 they were five and
five yeah through ten games before they
found the gas pedal and the next thing
you know they're winning the Super Bowl
yeah I know II don't know if there's
gonna be that team that emerges so you
know from the middle of the pack right
now that kind of surprises us all I
don't know if I see that happening this
year I mean I do look at teams like the
Rams and the Cowboys at four and three
and still go they are extremely
dangerous watch out for them so I guess
that would classify but I think we have
a pretty a pretty good picture right now
of the teams that we think are real
contenders and especially your top two
teams I think that's right now if you
I'm picking 49ers Patriots Super Bowl
that's where we're going I think it's
gonna happen
the team that I look at in the middle of
the pack is a team that we had left for
dead last year about this time and they
found a way down the stretch even after
Carson Wentz was injured again to make
themselves relevant and crash the party
and win when they get there and I've got
ultimate faith in the ability of Doug
Peterson's Eagles to win games when
their backs are against the wall and
that's the Eagles who are right on your
back right now but we're gonna do its
Power Rankings time heading into week
eight let's start with the top of the
heap and as you said there are two teams
that have separated the Patriots at
number one the 49ers at number two
unchanged from last week the Saints at
number three unchanged from last week
the Packers jump up to number four by
virtue of the Seahawks losing they had
previously been number four ravens up to
to number five after beating Seattle
Bills holding steady at six because they
that you could argue that the bills
should drop after that lackluster
performance against Miami Seahawks down
to seven Vikings up three to number
eight after manhandling the Lions the
Chiefs at number nine unchanged the
Panthers at number 10 unchanged and
Chris the one that I really wrestled
with
dropping the Chiefs out of the top ten
because Patrick mahomes is injured but
the way I'm looking at it is look for
now you've earned your spot that's right
if you lose then you'll drop yeah I
agree I mean again they showed at least
you know some toughness and the ability
to handle some some tough circumstances
as far as last Thursday night and what
happened in that Broncos game and still
battled and played well on both sides of
the football
to to dominate the Denver Broncos the
big one I'm I'm like in alright so this
is where I want to your gut you have a
great gut all right
49ers Saints if they play to each other
how do you see that one kind of shaking
out right I mean what's what's your gut
they're like if you had a if they're to
play each other this Sunday how do you
think that game goes down while they are
playing each other later this season and
the first time I hear 49ers Saints I
think of that 2011 that epic playoff
game back and forth down the wire
I'd probably give that I probably give
the Saints the edge I think the Saints
right now are more battle-tested than
the 49ers the 49ers in hindsight have
not played a very strong schedule that's
the one thing with the Patriots and the
49ers strength of schedule based on 20
18 wins and losses I always hate or 2019
I always hate when we when we look at
his schedule and say well there's gonna
be a tough schedule based upon how all
the opponents did last year I don't care
about last year but I do care about this
year yeah and the strength of schedule
based on this year is gonna go up for
the Patriots and the 49ers moving
forward as evidenced by the fact that
the Saints are looming and other tough
games for the 49ers are coming and I
think right now and I've learned the
hard way every time I think the Saints
are walking into a buzz saw
they are the buzz saw yeah and we saw
three days ago in Chicago so right now
if they were playing this weekend I
would pick the Saints okay
so why didn't you make them number two I
had a feeling you were gonna say that
that's why I asked the question so why
would you make them number two and you
think they would beat the damn 49ers
this weekend you outlaw iord the lawyer
that's pretty good well I talked them
into a corner or I didn't do anything I
just wait a minute yourself into a
corner you've just said that you believe
the patrons in the 49ers are the best
two teams in the NFL
I had a feeling that if I asked you
about the 49ers in the Saints you were
gonna set the Saints with win I just had
a feeling I know you too well so so I
just want to say question you should
have the Saints as number two go ahead
because power rankings are independent
of what would happen between two teams
they got on the field at the same time
I'm sure that I have picked teams lower
in the power rankings to win when
playing a team hired the Power Rankings
I did it last week foolishly thinking
the Raiders were gonna beat the Green
Bay Packers so the power rankings are
unrelated this is not a tool for
predicting outcomes this is a
recognition of where teams currently are
and so I can tell you that if they were
playing this weekend next week the
Saints would be number two how about
okay whatever mr. three-way tie a few
weeks ago in your Power Rankings
whatever all right so let me get this I
like this this is fun I like picking
your crap apart here all right so now
now you got that so you the Packers
though I'm cool with them at number four
I get you there you wanted you put the
Ravens in front of the bills though huh
that's I just want to ask you there to
loss Ravens team they did enough last
week to prove to you that they they
belong there okay okay yeah because that
four and two felt a little fraudulent
going into this week but to go to
Seattle and do what they did to the
Seahawks when the Bills had to screw
around with the Dolphins it was 14 - 9
and if it's tragic remar jannat victory
the bills were sweating in that game and
I wasn't impressed enough to bump them
up a spot because this was about who
gets bumped up and I don't think the
bills that I couldn't in good conscience
move the bills from 6 to 5 after what I
saw on Sunday yeah ok I understand that
I wouldn't know I don't think I would
have either I'm actually shocked that
you didn't put the Vikings a little
higher now that's what I want to ask you
about why not the Vikings in front of
the Seahawks over the bills I mean they
got some quality wins they're playing
really good football right now I could
argue that they've played better quality
football maybe than the Seattle Seahawks
have the last few weeks
well can I say that I didn't put the
Vikings in front of the Seahawks because
I think the Seahawks would beat the
Vikings right now that that arguments
out the window
I had to pick one of the other and I
think the body will work for the
Seahawks and the quality to the team for
the Seahawks and and look they just
think the Seahawks right now Russell
Wilson and a big moment more than you do
striking so I get you there I just
wanted to test you and and if I would
have tied them at seven then you
wouldn't let me hear the end of it for
the next three witnesses maybe yes if
you come with another tie on these Power
Rankings I might have to walk off the
set okay you can't do that there's no
tie well thank you Kings now you've made
no you made it very very attractive for
me to come with another to leave the set
if you make a tie then finally all right
go ahead sorry let's look at let's look
at the next 10 because that's when we
get into the middle of pack we were
talking about earlier the teams that
maybe can find that way out of the weeds
and become a serious deep playoff run
type of a team Colts at four and two up
six spots I got to give them credit
after beating the Texans the Rams are
unchanged at number 12 because after all
they barely well they didn't barely beat
the Falcons they beat a team that is
barely a team is what I meant to say
Cowboys I had a problem at the cap I
mean the Cowboys won big Chris but I
there was nowhere I could put them I
couldn't put them any higher I wasn't
gonna put them above the Rams because
the Rams won big and maybe it's just the
Eagles aren't all that good although I
didn't drop the Eagles very far we're
getting into a spot here where there's a
lot of mediocre teams right and when
there's a lot of mediocre teams it's
hard to justify movement so I felt bad
not giving the Cowboys a bump up I felt
bad not dropping the Eagles more than
one spot even though it was a thirty
seven to ten outcome but that's where it
ended cowboys at 13 Texans at 14 down
from 8 Eagles down 1 to 15 Raiders
unchanged at 16 even though they lost
Jags up 7 to number 17 the Steelers
moved up 1 by not playing the number 18
Lions down 1 from 18 to 19 and the
Titans get a 5 but well after winning
against the Chargers on Sunday they're
at number 20 yes I mean it's really
tough to draw lines when you just have
this cluster of teams that you really
don't believe in and you got to figure
out how
fit together and you don't want to be
unfair to any of them yeah but there
really isn't anybody that stands out
right now no I I get it it is it's a
it's a big cluster and really the the
big one to me and you mentioned it a
little bit was the Eagles you know the
Eagles I get what you're saying I mean
they are the ultimate you know backs
against the wall type of team us against
the world
but man I I got questions about the
Eagles right now I don't know I mean
that they got to get healthy first
that's gonna be the big issue and if
they don't get healthy soon the season
might be lost before they have a chance
to really fight back and back themselves
out of a corner it's just not a good
look right now the defense isn't playing
well and of course they're banged up in
the secondary defensive line not as
dominant you know there's no big Pike's
threat who are you scared of on the
Philadelphia Eagles on offense right now
they only got to be scared of as Carson
Wentz I mean he's the only like legit
legit playmaker they have it's a lot of
work for them to move the ball up and
down the field I'm concerned about them
I don't know where this is gonna go
could very easily see them losing to
Buffalo and Buffalo this week oh
absolutely and and look they may be a
team that digs out of that all you said
earlier the Cowboys are three and five
last year and they won the division
right the Eagles may parlay three and
five and is something they really need
to Shawn Jackson back he was so great
week one but you know the one thing that
I thought would derail the Eagles this
year hasn't happened Carson Wentz hasn't
gotten injured but all these other
injuries around him has made it
difficult for this team to be
competitive
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports